こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
フィッシャーズのシルクくん
4ちゃん
ご結婚
おめでとうございます
めでたいよ
素晴らしいおめでたい結構おめでとう
ございますはい皆さん知ってますかあの
YouTuberのビッグカップルが誕生
しましたフィッシャーのシルク元万有のゆ
んちゃんあの2人が結構発表しましたお
めでとうございます
[拍手]
お
[音楽]
[拍手]
めでとうございますいやーめでたいよ
めでたいと言うかですねこれ俺言っていい
のかなママ発表されてるからいいでしょう
あのね俺知ってたのよシルクとゆんちゃん
がお付き合いしてたの知ってたんです
けれども誰にも言ってなくてもマジで誰も
言ってない
ね
信頼してくれて話してくれたんだと思い
ますけど僕ずっと知っててうわあついに
結婚したのかと思って知ってたからその
突然えっみたいな
反応じゃなくてあついに結構したんだって
いうあの純粋に
ゴールしたなっていうお祝いの気持ちで
発表を見ておりました
[音楽]
取り残されてきたなぁ別にあの結婚が全て
ではないって分かりますけどももう本当に
最近あのもうちょっとプリン食べながら
話しますあのめでたいのはもちろんわかる
んですけどもいつ個人の感想としては
[音楽]
取り残されたなと取り残されたなと思って
しまうわけですよもちろん誰しもが結婚し
てるわけではないんですよわかりますただ
その東海オンエアのてつやとか
フィッシャーズのシルクとか同年代同い年
のこの世代の人たちがみんな結婚していく
のを見て
[音楽]
あってなるわけですね
間違いなくお似合いの2人ですよなんかね
2人ともね心が
綺麗な印象がすごいある
価値観が合ってるって本人たちも言ってた
しあれはもうね素敵な夫婦になること
間違いないですでちょっと第三者のはじめ
社長が言ってる動画ですこのあの外部から
のただのあのいつ感想だからはじめ社長は
そう思ってんだぐらいでよかったら聞いて
ください
結婚ねー
ゼクシィ今月の付録なんだろうなおおクマ
のプーさんの名前バッグが付いてましたね
可愛らしい
プーさんのバッグですね
[音楽]
やっぱそろそろなのかな
そろそろ内容な気もしますねえだってさえ
ヒカキンさんはの結婚されてないでしょえ
大丈夫かなそろそろ突然したりしないよな
ただフィッシャーズとか東海オンエアー
もう全員が結婚してるわけじゃないんです
よまさに結婚するちょっと聞いてみよう
視力てつや結婚なるほどねちょっとあの
個人的にマサイが結婚したらマジでもう
より忘れます今回のねシルクがもうゆん
ちゃんとお付き合いしてるっていうのが
知ってたのでそこまで大きな大打撃という
か
置いてかれたみたいなことにはなってない
ので皆さんご安心くださいはじめしゃ
ちょーのメンタルは今回保たれてます
むしろおめでとって気持ちがもうかなり
強い毎回そう思ってるんですけどもやっぱ
ね同世代の人が結婚すると自分と
照らし合わせてしまいますよね人と比べる
のは良くないっていうのはよくわかってる
んですけれどもそうとはいえども見られる
からさ見られる仕事だから世間からこう
比較されるわけが少なくともでも
Twitterでなんか出回ってきたのが
その哲也と峯岸南ちゃんと今回の視力と
ユンちゃんの結婚しましたっていう画像を
こうやってバンって2つ貼ってやって
どっちがいいみたいなアンケート取ってた
ツイート見たんですけども比較がすんなー
次は人の幸せでもなんかめっちゃはあって
思いながら昨日は静かに寝ました
隣にサービスを添えてまず結婚するのも
どうかと思いますし
結婚してる人をしない人を比較するのも
どうかと思います
やっぱたくさん来るのよはじめん初めは
結婚するのとかしないのと初めもそろそろ
だねなんか来るけど言われれば言われる
ほど気にするからなやめてくれよただ
みんなきっと心配してくれて俺に言って
くれてるんでしょうありがとう
結婚ねーうーん
今回のシルクとゆんちゃんの結婚受けて
まあ本当に
純粋におめでとうという気持ちと
[音楽]
焦り
いやまた50/50というかどうなん
でしょうねそもそも俺今のこの生活のまま
結婚できるのかって言われるとすごい不安
なんですよごめんね突然俺のなんか
結婚ガチ話みたいになっちゃってますけど
はじめしゃちょーのメインチャンネルを
やりつつ今サブチャンネル始めちゃった2
もやりながらはじめしゃちょーの畑も最近
結構出るようにしてましてもうずっと出
てるんですよ
あれお嫁さんに使ってあげる時間はあるの
かとあでもそこどうなんだろうなそこは
もう
理解してるしかないのかなやばいもう
先走っちゃって結婚した後の話を考えて
しまってますけどもうわもう先走っちゃっ
ても結婚した後の話をしてしまうそれ
ぐらいなんか自分でこう妄想しながらも
結婚の後のストーリーできれば離婚とかし
たくないですし子供も欲しい幸せな家庭を
傷に幸せな生活を送っていきたいと思い
ますがまあなかなかそうそう今の生活で
それができるかなって言われるちょっと
できないですねうんいやできるのかな人
次第か相手時代にはなっちゃうからそう
いうのはもう本当にYouTuberと
ユーチューバーの結婚か同じ職業だとどう
なっちゃうんだろうねでもなんか理解は
ありそうですねお互いの理解
いいなそれはそれであの結婚のちょっと
先輩として許諾書に連れてきました
よろしくお願いしますまずおめでたいです
よねおめでとうございます本当知ってた
いや知らなかった本当にずっと知ってたの
よいやすごいない
口が硬い男どうでしょうかちょっと焦っ
ちゃうよね
でも今回知ってたから
ぎりダメージはそんな少ないみたいな
ダイソンはどうですか結婚してみていやー
でも楽しいっすよやっぱ本当に好き
[音楽]
愛してる愛してる
YouTuberの人とか同業者と結婚し
たって感じじゃないですけどもはいはい
はいどうですかそこら辺は理解とかあり
ますいやもうねやっぱりYouTuber
の方と例えば一般の方僕みたいなパターン
なんですけどやっぱりね違うじゃないです
か
やっぱりどうしてもお付き合いしてる中で
相手にちょっとわかってもらうというのが
やっぱり大事かなと今の
奥さんはそこ編理解してくれてるんで本当
にもう感謝です
マサイからですね予定ないですといただき
ましたおめでとうございます
はいというわけでえーとユンちゃんと
シルクちゃんあ違ったシルクちゃんとユン
さんのあれ
2人で1つだからどっちでもいっか視力と
ユンちゃんの結婚本当おめでとうござい
ますはいあのー本当にね
急な発表で皆さん驚かれたかと思います
けれどもまあもう年そういう年なのかも
しれないねこの台はこの後はちょっとあの
HIKAKINさんとか俺とかもちょっと
わかんないですどうなるかわかんないです
独身を貫く可能性もあるのかな
わかんないですねマジでちょっとだいぶ
増えたな結婚してる人がはいあのー
たのかなって周りの人が結婚すればする
ほど思ってしまいますさあこんな感じの
社長が結婚できるタイミングが来るん
でしょうかお楽しみに
もしもし
お疲れ様ですはい家に建物です
[音楽]